(audience claps)
- Were you ever asked
to do impressions of
humans at an audition?
- [Cheryl] Oh no.
- Are you good at that?
- Apparently, no.
(Kelly laughs)
I auditioned for...
I think it was one of the...
I don't even remember the
name of the movie now.
Like a "Scream."
It was one of the funny-
- Like a scary movie?
- [Cheryl] Oh, "Scary Movie"!
- Oh, it's called "Scary Movie."
Yeah, the "Scary Movies."
- [Cheryl] It was like
"Scary Movie 3" or something.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the whole audition was.
(Cheryl hesitates)
(Kelly laughs)
I was auditioning,
in the film,
the mom from the "Exorcist"
takes the priest's hat
and she's about to hang it up
and she catches herself in the mirror
and she puts it on and realizes,
"Oh, I should do a Michael
Jackson impersonation,"
and so my whole audition was me,
"Yee hee."
(audience laughs)
And I am moonwalking
and dancing around and-
- What?
- Yeah.
It was one of those
out-of-body experiences.
I saw myself, and I was like, "No, no.
"Don't moonwalk."
- [Kelly] Don't do it.
- "Don't moonwalk."
And I did.
- [Kelly] Did it.
- Sure did.
- [Kelly] You leaned in.
- I leaned in and didn't get it.
- [Kelly] And they leaned out.
- They leaned out.
(Kelly laughs)
I heard that they ended up not
using the scene in the film
or something like...
Somebody said something
to make me feel better.
I don't know.
(Kelly laughs)
- I felt as they just
didn't need that part.
- [Cheryl] They did not need that part.
- You've been asked to do random things.
- The life of an actor is crazy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.